.
* Der Hahn kräht. *
* Sanfte, dynamische Musik *
(Radiomoderatorin) Guten Morgen.
Wie sieht die Landwirtschaft
der Zukunft aus?
Der Bundesrat
hat seine Vorstellungen
mit der Agrarpolitik 2022+
skizziert.
Er möchte u.a. den Umweltschutz,
die Artenvielfalt
und das Tierwohl stärken.
... ausebnen.
- Ja, es hat schon ...
Na, fit und munter?
Die Vision ist eine Landwirtschaft,
bei der es allen gut geht.
Dem Boden, den Pflanzen, den Tieren.
Aber eben auch den Menschen.
Das Landwirtepaar
will mit 500 Genossenschaftern
zusammenarbeiten
und mit ihnen Kosten,
Arbeit und Ernte teilen.
Ich freue mich auf den Fenchel,
auf die erste Ernte.
Dann hegen und pflegen
wir den natürlich.
Der Geschmack ist viel intensiver.
Ich habe auch früher
Gemüse gegessen,
aber der Geschmack hier
ist so intensiv.
In der Schweiz schliessen
jedes Jahr rund 1'000 Betriebe.
Zu gross der Aufwand,
zu tief die Preise für ihre Produkte.
Auf diesem Hof
soll das wirtschaftliche Risiko
auf viele Schultern verteilt werden.
Ein Film über eine Idee,
wie Landwirtschaft
auch funktionieren könnte.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Wenn du deine Telefonate
beendet hast,
kannst du auch noch etwas
bei der Kirschernte helfen.
Ich habe dich herummotoren gehört
und dachte,
dir ist wieder etwas eingefallen.
An diesem Ast
waren sie wirklich früh.
Wir ernten recht aufwendig. Es ist
nicht so eine grosse Anlage hier.
Wir nehmen wirklich
nur die dunkelsten.
Man muss auch immer wieder
probieren, ob das Aroma stimmt.
So, ich gehe
mein Körbchen mal leeren.
Tina Siegenthaler und Finn Thiele
konnten den Hof
vor drei Jahren pachten.
Bei der Kirschenernte könnten sie
jede Hand gut gebrauchen.
Sie sind auch schon reif,
aber noch nicht rot.
Der Obstbau ist ein gutes Beispiel.
Was wir hier machen,
könnte viel ökologischer sein.
Aber das ist
mit mehr Aufwand verbunden.
Wenn wir ein paar Leute hätten,
die uns unterstützen,
die den finanziellen Aufwand und
den Arbeitsaufwand tragen helfen,
dann ist es möglich.
Wenn man für den Markt produziert,
macht man viele Abstriche,
die man gern vermeiden würde.
Es gibt Dinge, für die man gern Zeit
hätte, aber es liegt nicht drin.
Für manche Dinge
kriegt man ja kein Geld.
Du kannst den Hof
noch so schön aufräumen,
bezahlt wirst du dafür nicht.
Der biologische Landbau
ist Knochenarbeit.
Wir müssen
die Ackerkratzdistel bekämpfen.
Denn wenn die Überhand nimmt,
hast du einfach weniger Futter.
Wir setzen dafür
keine giftigen Mittel ein,
sondern machen das mit der Sense.
Wir haben mal
eine Arbeitszeiterfassung gemacht,
um Bescheid zu wissen. Wir liegen
bei 250-300 Std. im Monat.
Das sind
fast doppelt so viele Stunden
wie ein normaler Arbeitnehmer
leistet.
Dafür zahlen sie sich momentan
je 1'700 Fr. Lohn aus.
* Sie lacht. *
Zurzeit sind 35 Rinder auf dem Hof.
Ihr Fleisch
ist eine wichtige Einnahmequelle.
Diese Tiere sind eigentlich
die sog. überzähligen Kälber
aus der Milchwirtschaft.
Die Kuh muss ja jedes Jahr ein Kalb
gebären, damit sie Milch gibt,
und nicht jedes Kalb
kann zu einer Milchkuh werden.
Dann kommen die Tiere, wenn sie etwa
sechs Monate alt sind, zu uns,
fressen die steilen Hänge leer
und machen aus dem Gras und Klee,
das wir Menschen nicht essen können,
eigentlich Gülle und Mist,
die wir für die Bodenfruchtbarkeit
als Dünger verwenden, und Fleisch,
das wir wiederum essen können.
Die Tiere sind jedoch
ein Diskussionspunkt.
Es zeichnet sich ab,
dass wir weniger Tiere haben werden.
Es gehört dazu, dass Finn und ich,
die den Hof führen,
eine Art Grundoffenheit für be-
triebliche Änderungen haben müssen.
Die beiden teilen sich den Hof
mit der Gemüsekooperative ortoloco.
* Fröhliches Gespräch *
Auf gemeinsamen Anbau setzen in der
Schweiz bislang rund 70 Kooperativen.
U.a. in Bern, Basel
und v.a. in der Westschweiz.
In Dietikon bei Zürich produziert
ortoloco ausschliesslich Gemüse
und verteilt es wöchentlich
an die 500 Mitglieder.
Als Gegenleistung
verpflichten sie sich für ein Jahr
und bezahlen
einen fixen Beitrag im Voraus.
Als Genossenschafterin arbeitet Ruth
Meyer Kopp mehrere Tage im Jahr mit.
So wie alle Mitglieder.
Die Gnossis leisten 70 %
der betrieblichen Arbeiten.
Wieso arbeitest du hier mit?
Weil es mir Freude bereitet.
Und mit einem grossen Garten,
den viele Menschen bewirtschaften,
ist man unabhängiger. Man kann
dann kommen, wenn man Zeit hat.
Wenn man im Sommer weg ist,
in den Ferien oder so,
machen andere die Arbeit
und das Gemüse geht nicht kaputt.
Die Gemüsekooperative hat
drei angestellte Gärtner:innen.
Die kannst du nehmen.
Grundsätzlich
lieber zu früh als zu spät,
weil wir viele Früchte
an der Pflanze lassen.
Darum muss man sie regelmässig
ernten, sonst macht sie keine neuen.
Genau.
Also diese vier kann ich nehmen?
Die würde ich alle nehmen. Alle,
die eine sich lohnende Grösse haben.
Die da oben?
- Die kannst du auch nehmen.
Ich komme nicht rauf.
Die wächst noch etwas weiter.
Wir bauen eigentlich alles an,
was unsere Gnossis gern essen.
Es sind wohl insgesamt
50 verschiedene Kulturen.
Wir machen die Anbauplanung jeweils
Ende Jahr fürs folgende Jahr.
Da steht alles drauf,
ziemlich übersichtlich:
Was wie lang auf welchem Beet ist.
Jedes Beet ist eingezeichnet.
Wir haben 13 Parzellen,
und unsere Fruchtfolge
geht immer von Parzelle zu Parzelle.
Zehn Jahre nach der Gründung
bildet ortoloco das Fundament für
den nächsten Schritt: den ganzen Hof
mit dem Getreide, dem Obst und den
Rindern solidarisch bewirtschaften.
Es ist viel konsequenter, wenn man
einen ganzen Hof solidarisch führt
und nicht einfach nur
einen Betriebszweig.
Bisher war es das Gemüse, aber
dieses ist auch abhängig vom Hof,
z.B. wegen des Mists, der Flächen,
der Infrastruktur.
Das gibt dann schnell
ein Ungleichgewicht.
Das Gartenteam ist wirklich super,
die haben super Arbeitsbedingungen.
Die Genossenschafterinnen und
Genossenschafter sind dabei,
das Gemüse ist wirklich
solidarisch produziert.
Aber der Hof, der einen Teil
der Gemüseproduktion
überhaupt erst ermöglicht,
wird nicht solidarisch geführt.
In Zukunft sollen
die Genossenschafter:innen
auf dem ganzen Hof
mit seinen 20 ha mitarbeiten.
Heute informieren sich die Mitglieder
der Gemüsekooperative darüber,
was auf dem Hof produziert wird
und welche neuen Lebensmittel
dazukommen könnten.
Gut. Wir haben insgesamt
jetzt so um die 7 ha Ackerland,
das wir bewirtschaften.
Darauf haben wir
eine sog. Fruchtfolge.
D.h., wir pflanzen nicht jedes Jahr
dasselbe auf jeder Parzelle,
sondern es rotiert.
Bisher war der Mais ziemlich wichtig
für die Winterfütterung der Rinder,
damit die nicht vom Fleisch fallen -
wortwörtlich.
Klassisch ist auch der Dinkel.
Der braucht im Gegensatz zum Weizen
extrem wenig Nährstoffe.
Und ein sehr wichtiger Teil
der Fruchtfolge ist die Kunstwiese.
Sie ist extrem wichtig
für den Biolandbau
bzw. allgemein
für die Landwirtschaft,
denn sie gönnt dem Boden eine Pause.
Sind Linsen künftig eine Option?
Ihr habt viel mehr Weizen als Mais,
z.B.
Wenn du vom Boden ausgehst:
In welcher Form geht das auf
mit den Tieren?
Würde das die Anzahl Tiere, die der
Hof sozusagen braucht, reduzieren?
Warum macht ihr hier mit?
Aus Lebensfreude und weil wir
gern unser eigenes Gemüse haben,
von dem wir wissen, woher es kommt
und wie es produziert wurde.
Und ich, weil ich
wirklich gern mitarbeite,
weil ich gern mit der Erde arbeite
und auch von daher komme,
von der Kindheit an.
Und es ist generationenübergreifend.
Hier sind viele junge Leute
und auch ein paar ältere, wie wir.
Das ist auch noch
ein schöner Gedanke.
Ich finde es mega wichtig,
dass unsere Gesellschaft
sich mit Themen wie Umwelt,
Ernährung usw. auseinandersetzt.
Es gibt natürlich auch die Utopie
dazu: Selbstversorgung ist toll!
Und am Ende hast du etwas,
das du essen kannst,
und das ist geil,
weil du es selber gemacht hast.
Das versuche ich auch weiterzugeben.
Manchmal rede ich aber an eine Wand.
Die Leute denken:
"Ach, das ist so einer."
Ich habe noch selten
jemanden überreden können,
der sagte:
"Voll geil, da mache ich mit."
Es heisst immer:
"Aber es kostet ja sehr viel."
"Ich habe keine Zeit."
"Es ist schön, aber ein Privileg für
die, die es sich leisten können."
Das ist das, was ich zu 80 % höre.
Aber das ist mir egal.
Gut. Thema Finanzen.
Es freut mich sehr, dass sich
so viele dafür interessieren.
Es ist ja immer etwas trocken und
manchmal schreckt das die Leute ab.
Tex Tschurtschenthaler ist Buchhalter
und einer der Mitgründer
der Gemüsekooperative.
Etwas Obst und Most.
Wie ist denn der Vergleich
zum Einkaufen im Bioladen?
Das kannst du nicht vergleichen.
Das sind andere Betriebe.
Und im Laden hast du einen
Zwischenhändler, der auch Geld will.
Das ist einfach nicht vergleichbar.
Um die jährlichen Betriebskosten
des gesamten Hofs zu decken,
sind voraussichtlich 740'000 Fr.
an Einnahmen durch die Abos nötig.
Ein Voll-Abo mit allen Produkten
würde 2'850 Fr. im Jahr kosten
oder 240 Fr. im Monat.
Noch ist nicht sicher,
ob diese Rechnung wirklich aufgeht.
Vieles ist unklar.
Der Aufbau einer solidarischen
Landwirtschaft braucht Zeit.
20 besonders engagierte Gnossis
leisten die Denk-
und Organisationsarbeit.
Die meisten ehrenamtlich.
Gemeinsam wollen sie den Hof nicht
nur bewirtschaften, sondern kaufen.
Die Idee: ortoloco gibt der GmbH
von Finn und Tina ein Darlehen.
Nötig ist ein Betrag
jenseits der Million.
Das mit dem Hofkauf wird uns wirk-
lich noch richtig durchschütteln.
Bei uns wird die Arbeit
auf dem Hof auch nicht weniger.
Gerade wenn ich all diese Äpfel
an den Bäumen hängen sehe -
die fallen nicht von allein runter.
Also ...
Wenn wir ganz ehrlich sind, haben
wir die 1,4 noch nicht beisammen.
Auch mit den unverbindlichsten
Zusagen noch nicht.
Aber wir haben
einen grossen Teil beisammen
mit den unverbindlichen Zusagen,
teils schon mit den verbindlichen.
Dann stellt sich dann heraus,
ob wir noch ein paar 100'000
von der Bank holen können.
Aber das ist
nicht matchentscheidend.
Wenn wir sagen,
wir wollen uns diesen Hof leisten
und dafür
wollen wir Anteilscheine sammeln.
Das ist mal einfach das,
was wir wollen.
Ob das klappt,
steht noch in den Sternen.
Noch gehört der Hof ihm:
Samuel Spahn.
35 Jahre hat er darauf
gewirtschaftet.
Nun will er verkaufen.
Ein wichtiger Teil ist das da,
das ist die Basis.
Aber wir haben noch etwas Land
da unten beim Rangierbahnhof
und auch gleich hier unten am Hügel,
da gehört auch noch etwas dazu.
Kommen Sie den Käufern
der Genossenschaft entgegen?- Ja.
Wieso?
Aus ideellen Gründen.
Aus ...
Ich ...
Ich habe nie schlecht gelebt,
aber das Geld war nie
mein wichtigster Antrieb,
um etwas zu machen.
Sein ganzes Leben
hat sich der Biopionier
der Landwirtschaft verschrieben.
Von den jetzigen Pächtern wollte er
sich zuerst ein Bild machen.
Ich habe auch verlangt,
dass sie eine Ausbildung haben.
Das kam auch von mir.
Ich möchte keine Halbschuhe hier,
die irgendetwas machen.
Ich möchte, dass sie etwas
von der Sache verstehen.
Ich habe auch mal
eine Meisterprüfung gemacht
und mich auch stetig weitergebildet.
Ohne das geht es schlicht nicht.
Das ist auch in der Landwirtschaft
auch so.
Tex Tschurtschenthaler
will keine Zeit verlieren.
Bald erfährt er, ob die Genossen-
schafter und Genossenschafterinnen
bereit sind, den Kauf des Hofs
mit Anteilsscheinen zu finanzieren.
In seinem Atelier
am Stadtrand von Zürich
werden jeden Moment die Resultate
der virtuellen GV aufgeschaltet.
So - 17.53, es dauert noch 7 Min.
Aber ich logge mich schon mal ein.
Etwas angespannt?
- Ich bin schon sehr neugierig, ja.
Doch.
Abstimmen kann man
schon mal nicht mehr.
Hey! Okay.
Es ist sonnenklar,
es ist gar keine Frage.
Wow.
- Was ist das Resultat?
Ja, ähm ...
Die drei Darlehensanträge
sind mit 112 von 114
bzw. 109 von 113
bzw. 113 von 115 angenommen worden.
Es ist also eindeutig.
Ortoloco will den Hof kaufen, ja.
Ja, cool.
Mmh.
Also, dann machen wir das.
Ein Projekt scheint auf Kurs.
Doch Tex Tschurtschenthaler
möchte mehr.
Er will mithelfen, die Idee
auch in die Berge zu bringen.
Die Surselva, Kanton Graubünden.
Hier soll die erste solidarische
Landwirtschaft, kurz Solawi,
in den Bergen entstehen.
Eine Perspektive für die
unter Druck stehenden Bergbauern.
Ich vermarkte alle Produkte,
die ich habe, direkt.
Ich habe einen kleinen Kundenkreis
aufgebaut, v.a. im Unterland.
Meist metzge ich
ein- bis zweimal im Jahr.
Ich bin bis zum letzten Moment
bei meinen Tieren dabei.
Ich halte sie.
Das wäre nicht möglich,
wenn ich einfach an einen Kanal für
die Grossverteiler liefern würde.
Dann werden sie hier abgeholt
und ins Unterland gefahren
zum Schlachten.
Ich mag es, wenn ich weiss,
wohin meine Produkte gehen.
So bekomme ich auch gleich etwas
von der Wertschätzung mit.
Das stand für mich zuoberst,
als ich mich für die Solawi
zu interessieren begann:
Den Kontakt zu den Kunden
zu intensivieren.
Darum kam ich auf die Solawi,
das war der erste Gedanke.
Jonas Lei
kommt ursprünglich aus Zürich
und pachtet den Betrieb
seit vier Jahren.
Ich mag die Landschaft hier sehr.
Das Wilde, teils Archaische,
das sie noch hat.
Das gefällt mir hier oben sehr.
Bauer bin ich, weil ich
den Umgang mit den Tieren sehr mag.
Auch die Arbeit
mit den Pflanzen gefällt mir.
Sei es auf der Wiese, im Wald ...
Wovon lebst du denn, Jonas?
Primär von den Direktzahlungen
und von den Produkten meiner Tiere.
Der Umsatz liegt wohl ungefähr
bei 60'000 total.
Genau.
Was am Ende bleibt,
sind so 10'000 bis 15'000.
Davon lebst du?
- Davon lebe ich, ja.
Diesen Jahresgewinn
erwirtschaftet er allein.
Der Betriebserhalt ist momentan
eigentlich das grösste Projekt.
* Klopfen *
Teil des Solawi-Projekts
ist auch Sep Candinas in Sumvitg.
Der Bergbauer
hat verschiedene Standbeine.
Nebenbei machen wir Trockenmauern.
Das Hauptziel ist sicher,
die Biodiversität zu fördern.
Ich habe mir auch schon überlegt,
mehr solche Dinge zu machen.
Eine Idee war auch,
das hauptberuflich zu machen.
Aber körperlich, gesundheitlich
geht diese Haltung nicht jeden Tag.
Wenn du das zwei Tage gemacht hast,
musst du irgendetwas machen,
bei dem du halbwegs gerade stehst.
* Er schnalzt und pfeift fröhlich. *
Sep Candinas kann sich vorstellen,
seinen Betriebszweig Obst in die
solidarische Landwirtschaft zu geben.
Mit den Obstbäumen wird es
langsam ein bisschen zu viel.
Ich bin auch nicht mehr der Jüngste.
Und wenn ich sehe, wie viel Most es
in ein paar Jahren geben könnte
und wir gleichzeitig das mit dem auf
dem Markt gehen aufgegeben haben,
haben wir Mühe, das an den Mann
oder die Frau zu bringen.
Die Idee der solidarischen
Landwirtschaft wäre,
dass sie mir bei der Ernte helfen,
das Obst aber
auch gleich haben können.
So weiss ich ganz sicher,
dass es verwertet wird.
Denn das kann ich nicht ab,
wenn es einfach am Boden liegt.
Und so zahle ich auch nicht drauf,
es ist ein Nullsummenspiel.
Von der Solawi
würde dann meine Arbeit entschädigt.
Wovon lebst du?
Finanziell zuerst mal
von den Direktzahlungen, absolut.
Und dann
vom landwirtschaftlichen Betrieb.
Mutterkuhhaltung haben wir,
und 50 Hennen. Das wär's dann schon.
Sep weiss noch nicht,
wann er aufhört.
Und auch nicht,
was dann mit seinem Hof passiert.
Momentan gibt es so etwas noch nicht
in der Schweiz, so viel ich weiss,
dass ein Hof nicht mehr
dem Landwirt gehört,
sondern einem Verein
der solidarischen Landwirtschaft -
wie wir einen gegründet haben -
der später eine Genossenschaft
werden soll.
* Trompeten-Musik *
Vor einem halben Jahr ist Samuel
Spahn zusammen mit seiner Frau
in eine Stadtwohnung gezogen.
Zurück auf seinen Hof
kommt er v.a. zum Musizieren.
Das hat für mich Lebenswerkqualität.
Überall, wo ich hinschaue, sehe ich
meine Arbeit der letzten 35 Jahre.
Es gab Zeiten, in denen ich
eine Hassliebe zu diesem Ort hatte.
Ich war hier,
hatte meine Möglichkeiten,
aber es war verdammt anstrengend
und ich habe extrem viel gearbeitet.
Ich hatte in der Saison
des Öfteren 70-Std.-Wochen.
Ich habe wirklich
sehr viel und sehr hart gearbeitet.
Aber das war nicht das Schlimmste,
sondern, dass mich viele andere
Dinge auch noch interessiert hätten.
Da lag neben diesem
arbeitsintensiven Bio-Betrieb
mit seiner
sehr vielseitigen Betriebsstruktur,
also Obst, Ackerbau, Tiere,
Direktverkauf,
halt leider nicht alles drin, was
man auch noch gern gemacht hätte.
Ich habe gut gelebt,
wir haben gut gelebt auf dem Hof,
aber es reichte nicht,
um Ersparnisse anzuhäufen.
Ich habe zwar AHV, aber Bauern
haben keine Pensionskasse.
Wir hatten erst relativ spät Geld,
um eine dritte Säule zu äufnen,
Das reicht nicht weit.
Alle meine Ersparnisse, alles, was
ich erarbeitet habe in meinem Leben,
steckt in diesem Hof.
Sonst habe ich nichts.
Darum muss ich ihn verkaufen,
nun, da ich nicht mehr selber wirt-
schaftlich aktiv bin. So ist das.
Zu Hause bei Genossenschafterin
Ruth Meyer Kopp:
Die Gemüsefelder, von denen sie und
ihr Mann sich mehrheitlich ernähren,
liegen in Sichtweite.
Schön, wie sich die Äpfel
schneiden lassen.- Ja?
Für den Hofkauf überweisen die beiden
ein zinsloses Darlehen von 20'000 Fr.
Das ist die Ortoloco-Tasche:
Gurken, Auberginen, eine Zucchetti,
Bohnen mit Bohnenkraut, Salat,
Schnittmangold, ganz viele Tomaten,
Äpfel und Eier. Das ist die Fülle
dessen, was man in der Tasche hat.
Das reicht für eine Woche.
Wir sind froh, dass wir
das Abo mit jemandem teilen.
Zusammen kochen sie, was die Ernte
ein paar Tage zuvor hergibt.
Zu diesem Menü haben wir
diese Kartoffeln dazu gekauft.
Ginge es auch ohne Zukaufen?
Mmh ...
Kommt drauf an,
welche Zutaten man wählt.
Bei den Kartoffeln z.B.: Es gibt sie
auf dem Hof, aber nicht jetzt.
Was wir zusätzlich brauchen,
sind im Moment die Kohlehydrate.
Solawi hat ja vor, dass man auch
Weizen bzw. Pasta beziehen kann.
Im Moment, wo das noch nicht möglich
ist, kaufen wir das im Laden.
Jetzt kommen gerade
die Zwiebeln zum Zug.
Ich habe natürlich
auch früher Gemüse gegessen.
Aber seit wir das Gemüse
von ortoloco haben ...
Es hat einen sehr intensiven
Geschmack. V.a. die Tomaten.
Ich hatte noch nie solche Tomaten
wie diese von ortoloco.
Der Mangold braucht nicht länger,
oder?
Klar hält die Tasche nicht ewig.
Manchmal muss man sich
danach richten,
und manchmal gibt's für mich
auch etwas zu viel desselben.
Dann ist es halt mal so, dass es
zwei-, dreimal hintereinander
Ähnliches oder Gleiches gibt.
Super.
Ebenfalls. Dir auch.
Mmh. Mega fein.
Gerade jetzt, wo wir eine schwierige
Zeit haben mit diesem Virus
gab es eine grosse Nachfrage
nach regionalen Produkten,
Nahrungsmitteln.
Da ist man nicht
aufs Ausland angewiesen.
Das ist ein grosser Punkt, finde
ich. Das Thema Selbstversorgung.
Nicht, dass wir den Anspruch hätten,
uns komplett selbst zu versorgen,
in der heutigen Zeit. Aber wir
wollen wieder etwas zurückkommen.
Wir sind jetzt
zwei Fünfhundertstel Bauern,
von diesen 500 Genossenschaftern.
Auch in der Surselva
geht es vorwärts.
An diesem Wochenende
finden Schnuppertage
für die Solidarische Landwirtschaft
in den Bergen statt.
20 Personen aus dem Unterland packen
auf verschiedenen Betrieben mit an.
Dich würde ich dann
gleich vorausrennen lassen,
bevor die Kühe runterkommen.
Und zwar diese Strasse runter.
Es geht etwas 400 m hinunter,
dann gibt es eine Spitzkehre,
und an der Spitzkehre
haben sie eine neue Strasse gebaut,
die geradeaus geht.
Dort dürfen die Kühe nicht hin,
sie müssen die Kehre machen.
Die überrennen dich nicht.
Wenn die dich anschauen und du so
machst, gehen sie weg, ganz sicher.
* Drollige, gezupfte Streichklänge *
Aggressivität ist heute keine da.
Sonst könnten wir nicht
einfach so hinspazieren.
Bei einer Wanderung würde ich mich
nicht in die Herde hineintrauen.
Auch ich selber nicht.
Die erste Erfahrung im Kühetreiben,
die ich heute sammle.
In der Kindheit
habe ich mal Schafe getrieben,
aber das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich
eine andere Erfahrung.
Die Nähe zu den Tieren macht sicher
etwas mit einem, das glaube ich.
Was macht es mit dir?
Dass man gewisse Produkte
dann bewusster konsumiert.
Wir mussten
den Kot der Kühe verteilen,
damit die Nährstoffe vor dem Winter
etwas besser verteilt sind.
Das war mein Job.
Und ein paar Stecken wegtun.
Es ist super.
Mir gefällt solche Arbeit.
* Drollige, gezupfte Streichklänge *
Ich renne voraus, und dann
gibt es eine Haarnadelkurve,
wo auch eine Strasse geradeaus geht,
und die muss ich absperren
und hoffen, dass die Kühe
die Haarnadelkurve nehmen
und mich nicht überrennen.
Ich zähle, dann geht es los.
20!
Gehst du da hin und schaust,
dass sie nicht nach unten gehen?
Und du da hin und du schaust,
dass sie die Kurve nehmen.
* Sep pfeift. *
Es wäre auch ohne mich gegangen
in dieser Kurve.
Aber das konnten wir
vorher ja nicht wissen.
* Sep lacht. *
Oh!
Hey.
* Pfiff *
So, jetzt. Heieiei.
Sind alle hier?
- Gern.
Ui, das war ...
- ... etwas Action, was?
Ich habe den Eindruck, dass Sep
heute quasi zwei Herden hat,
nicht nur eine. Auch wir Menschen
funktionieren ein wenig wie Herden.
Ich stelle gerade
ein paar Dinge fest,
auf die wir dann
wirklich achten müssen,
wenn die Berg-Solawi
so richtig losgeht.
Sodass es für den Bauern mit uns
nicht mühsamer wird als ohne uns.
In Dietikon
stimmt die Genossenschaft darüber ab,
wie der Hof in Zukunft
bewirtschaftet werden soll.
In Zeiten der Pandemie
versammeln sich die Mitglieder
in der nahen Reithalle.
... in die Quartierdepots verteilt.
Ich hoffe und gehe davon aus,
dass die ausserordentliche
Generalversammlung
den vorliegenden Ideen zustimmt
und freue mich,
wenn der Hof so erhalten bleibt.
Als kleiner Ort mit grossen
Hoffnungen, als Bio-Oase
und als Beispiel dafür, dass
Landwirtschaft auch ohne Ausbeutung
von Mensch und Umwelt
funktionieren kann.
Was passiert,
wenn wir einen Totalschaden haben?
Das ist wie wenn man eine Firma hat.
Man hat halt
ein unternehmerisches Risiko.
Im Heft steht,
dass die Anzahl der Rinder
den Essgewohnheiten der Mitglieder
angepasst wird.
Darüber würde ich gern
ein bisschen mehr erfahren.
Das neue Hofkonzept, das Budget
und die geplanten Investitionen
werden mit grosser Mehrheit
angenommen.
Zwei Jahre Planung, Diskussionen
und Denkarbeit zahlen sich aus.
* Jubelrufe *
Für den Hofkauf
zeichnet jeder Haushalt
durchschnittlich 6'500 Fr. Anteils-
scheine Ð manche deutlich mehr.
Ich kann mehr geben
und gebe deshalb auch mehr,
weil es für mich so wichtig ist.
Ich kann Springereinsätze
übernehmen,
man kann mich anrufen, wenn man tags
darauf jemanden zum Fahren braucht.
Ich kann oft.
Dafür kann ich nicht viel Kapital
bieten, das dann festsitzt.
Denn mein Geldfluss ist ...
ein etwas anderer.
Ja, meine Partnerin und ich
haben gesagt,
dass wir 15'000 Fr.
in diese Anteilsscheine investieren.
Das ist ein Teil
unserer Altersreserve.
Aber wir haben das
im Bewusstsein dessen gemacht,
dass viele wenig Anteilsscheine
werden zeichnen können.
Wenn wir es können, machen wir es.
Ab nächstem Jahr
erhalten die beiden Landwirte
statt 1'700 je 4'100 Fr. Lohn.
* Gezupfte Streichklänge *
Heute geben Tina Siegenthaler
und Finn Thiele
ein Rind an einen Grossverteiler.
Voraussichtlich zum letzten Mal.
Von den Emotionen her, mei ...
Es war schön, dass es hier war
und hier eine schöne Zeit hatte.
Ich esse ja auch Fleisch, von daher
kann ich gut dahinterstehen.
Aber es ist schon
jedes Mal ein Abschied.
Man kriegt sie ja klein, und wenn
sie soweit sind, müssen sie gehen.
So.
Ab nächstem Jahr
sollen v.a. die Mitglieder
der Solidarischen Landwirtschaft
das Fleisch der Tiere konsumieren.
Ein Bio-Rind darf
nicht älter als 27 Monate sein
und sein Schlachtgewicht
nicht mehr als 280 kg betragen:
Das schreibt der Grossverteiler vor.
Es geht um das Gesamtgewicht.
Also das Schlachtgewicht
wird runtergefahren,
man muss sie früher abgeben -
dann, wenn sie eigentlich
den Knopf aufmachen würden.
Du musst sie schlachten, wenn sie
eigentlich zu wachsen beginnen?- Ja.
Das Argument ist:
Der Konsument soll kein zu grosses
Entrecote abgepackt bekommen,
weil das zu teuer wäre -
obwohl der Kilopreis ja gleich ist.
Ich mache hier mal zu.
Wir müssen wohl einfach kurz warten.
Komm, ein Schritt. Ein Schritt.
Hoppla.
Isst du Fleisch?
- Nein.
Ich mag Tiere, lebende Tiere.
Ich finde es auch schön,
wenn es sie gibt auf einem Hof,
genau wie Hunde und Katzen.
Aber natürlich,
wenn man sie schlachtet ...
... ist das halt für die,
die sie essen möchten richtig.
Wenn wir sehen, dass wir
zu viel Fleisch produzieren,
wird das ohnehin ein Thema.
Das wird nicht nur von mir kommen.
Aber ich würde es ansprechen,
wenn es niemand sonst tun würde.
Ich würde dann empfehlen,
weniger Rinder zu haben.
So. Und raus geht's. Allez, hopp!
Es ist halt so:
Wir brauchen die Gülle, den Mist,
um die Böden fruchtbar zu halten.
Es wäre ein ganz anderes Konzept,
so Landwirtschaft zu betreiben,
dass man mit Gründüngung
arbeiten würde
oder weniger Ertrag
in Kauf nehmen würde.
Ich denke, es wäre fahrlässig,
einfach runterzufahren
und mal zu schauen, was passiert.
Wir sind einfach noch nicht so weit,
die Anzahl Rinder zu reduzieren.
Das da unten wäre noch flach genug
für Ackerbau.
Aber weiter oben ist es zu steil.
Da macht es am meisten Sinn,
die Weiden einfach
von den Tieren abfressen zu lassen.
Denn sie machen daraus wertvollen
Dünger und Fleisch.
Und los!
So 20 bis 25 Tiere für die insgesamt
20 ha braucht es eigentlich schon.
Das habt ihr jetzt?
Jetzt haben wir etwas mehr.
Es wird ein ziemliches Herausfinden,
wie viel es verträgt,
wie viel wir runterfahren
und trotzdem die Bodenfruchtbarkeit
aufrecht erhalten können.
Bei Jonas Lei in Vals sind über das
Wochenende zwei Familien angereist.
Noch vor seinen Gästen muss er sich
um seine Schafe kümmern.
Einige könnten jeden Moment lammen.
Wie viele Schafe hast du denn?
Im Moment sind es ... 28.
Aber meistens sind es um die 25.
Ein paar Lämmer werden
jetzt dann noch geschlachtet,
ein paar verkaufe ich.
Dann sind es noch 24, 25.
Sonst stelle ich mir eher vor,
dass ein bis zwei Personen
gleichzeitig hier sind.
Dann habe ich auch Zeit für die
Leute bzw. kann sie so einsetzen,
dass sie mir wirklich helfen.
Wenn zu viele hier sind,
bin ich irgendwann nur noch
am organisieren und koordinieren.
Das soll ja nicht die Idee sein.
Sira, viens!
Viens.
Da unten ist gleich noch eine.
Das ist die Nachgeburt der Aue,
die gelammt hat.
Die frisst sie jetzt.
Ich lasse sie sie fressen,
damit sie weg ist.
Jetzt mit den Wölfen
wäre es sonst gut möglich,
dass sie durch die Nachgeburt
angezogen werden.
Jetzt gehe ich zu ihnen hin,
nehme das Lamm,
und versuche sie mit dem Lamm
in den Stall hinauf zu bringen.
Sira, viens!
* Blöken *
* Anrührende Klänge *
Sie werden zwischen neun Monaten
und einem Jahr alt.
Den nächsten Alpsommer
werden sie noch erleben.
* Sie kichern. *
* Drollige Musik *
Letzte Woche hat ein Sturm ziemlich
viele Bäume geknickt.
Jetzt habe ich die Weide geräumt.
Wie hat es dir gefallen?
- Sehr gut.
Was hat dir am besten gefallen?
Sicher das mit den Lämmchen.
Und Holz hier runter zu rollen
und zu werfen ist auch lustig.
Könntet ihr euch vorstellen,
dass wir eine Art kindergerechte
Mitarbeit organisieren,
die man reservieren kann, also wofür
sich nur Familien melden können?
Ich würde sowieso sagen, die Kinder
sollen keine Arbeitseinsätze haben,
sondern sie sind zum Vergnügen hier,
würde ich sagen.
Man soll nicht sagen, was sie
machen, sei auch Teil der Arbeit.
Dann stellt sich die Frage:
Verrichten dann die Eltern Arbeiten,
wo die Kinder mitkommen können
oder sind die Eltern frei,
machen die Arbeit, die nötig ist,
und jemand schaut zu den Kindern
und macht vielleicht noch den Stall?
Mit Kindern
ist es sehr unterschiedlich.
Auf Kinder in ihrem Alter
muss man nicht aufpassen.
Sie können sich selber beschäftigen
und wir können arbeiten.
Denkst du, so eine Mitarbeit
würde dir etwas bringen?
Definitiv, ja.
Denn sonst mache ich es allein.
Ohne die Leute der Solawi.
Nur schon heute Morgen
haben wir es gemerkt:
Wir waren den halben Morgen im Holz.
Und mit den sechs Leuten
ist unglaublich viel gelaufen.
Ich wäre mehr als ein Tag dran
gewesen, um das allein wegzuräumen.
Von daher: Ja, das bringt viel.
Wer bei der Solidarischen
Berglandwirtschaft mitmacht,
verpflichtet sich für drei Jahre.
Pro Jahr
sind drei Tage Mitarbeit geplant.
Dafür gibt's Fleisch,
Käse und Apfelmost.
Eine Mitgliedschaft
kostet 1'100 Fr. im Jahr.
Mit dem Potenzial,
etwas zu verändern,
mit den Produzenten
in einen Dialog darüber zu kommen,
was sie sich wünschen
und was für uns toll wäre,
einen Weg zu finden,
der an allen grossen
Vertriebskanälen vorbei geht:
Ja, das würde ich mir leisten.
Man muss es gern machen,
auch für die Sache einstehen.
Ich glaube,
dahinter steckt noch einiges mehr
als nur der finanzielle Beitrag
und die geleistete Arbeit.
Die Zeit ist reif dafür,
so zu denken.
Es passiert ja auch auf anderen
Ebenen einiges in die Richtung.
Daher bin ich zuversichtlich,
dass das klappen kann,
also dass es zumindest
als Experiment starten kann.
Wenn man Vegi ist, ist es mit
der Berg-Solawi natürlich schwierig.
Aber für mich finde ich es super.
Ich konsumiere diese Produkte
sowieso.
Und wenn ich sie auf diesem Weg
beziehen kann, ist es optimal.
Kannst du dir also
eine Mitgliedschaft vorstellen?
Ja.
* Kirchenglocken *
Das ist der erste
Berg-Solawi-Vertrag,
der hier unterschrieben wird.
Und? Ein gutes Gefühl?
Ja, super. Wunderbar, wirklich.
Oder?
- Ich denke schon, ja.
* Jubel *
(Alle) Viva!
Damit die Berg-Solawi funktioniert
mit den vorgesehenen fünf Betreiben,
brauchen wir etwa 400 Haushalte
mit gegen 1'000 Mitgliedern.
Wie viele habt ihr schon?
Hehe. Also ... Gestern und heute
kamen zehn oder zwölf zusammen.
Wenn man unsere Kerngruppe
dazu zählt, sind wir 20.
Es ist also noch ein sehr weiter Weg.
Hm, das sehe ich nicht so.
Sondern?
- Ich glaube, das geht schnell.
Das erste Produkt, Süssmost,
wird für die Verteilung
unter den Genossenschafter:innen
verladen.
Ein erster kleiner Schritt
ist gemacht:
(Sep) Du musst sie senkrecht lagern.
Wenn mich jemand
um eine sofortige Antwort bittet,
ob das funktionieren wird,
würde ich sagen: Eher nicht.
Aber ich lasse mich
dann gern überraschen.
Denn ich sehe auch,
dass wir erst am Anfang sind.
Und die Motivation der Leute,
was sie alles auf die Beine stellen,
überrascht mich immer wieder.
Immer wieder.
Ein Jahr später
umfasst die Genossenschaft
"Solidarische Landwirtschaft
in den Bergen" 40 Mitglieder.
Mittlerweile hat ein zweiter Hof
für das Projekt unterschrieben
und bald startet
die eigene Käseproduktion.
Dietikon.
Sechs Monate nach Gründung der Soli-
darischen Landwirtschaft ist klar:
Im ersten Jahr
wird die Genossenschaft
einen Verlust von 50'000 Fr.
schreiben.
Welches Unternehmen schreibt im
ersten Jahr schon schwarze Zahlen?
Es wäre ziemlich utopisch,
anzunehmen,
dass unser Budget
gleich von Anfang an aufgeht.
Einige Genossenschafter/-innen
sind im ersten Jahr
beim Gemüse-Abo geblieben
und haben noch nicht
auf ein Vollabo gewechselt.
Mittlerweile können die Mitglieder
auf dem Hof Getreide, das Fleisch
der Rinder, Öl und Tofu beziehen Ð
alles eigene Produkte.
Das Gemüse wird weiterhin
in eines der 17 Depots
in der Stadt Zürich gefahren.
Jede Woche übernimmt jemand anderes
den Abpack- oder den Fahrdienst.
Ready to go!
In den Depots
holen die Genossenschafter/-innen
ihr Essen ab.
* Polka-Musik *
Egal wie schwierig es manchmal ist
und wie oft es irgendwo klemmt,
es entsteht etwas.
Es ist nicht destruktiv,
es ist wirklich konstruktiv.
Und es ist erst der Anfang.
Man muss es mit einer
etwas anderen Haltung angehen.
Es geht nicht nur darum,
einen Bauernhof zu führen
und Lebensmittel zu produzieren -
natürlich steht das für mich
im Zentrum als Landwirtin -
aber es ist auch
ein gesellschaftliches Projekt,
bei dem es auch darum geht,
wie man das Ernährungssystem
transformieren kann.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Lilian Zbinden - 2021